Jurassic world is directed by Colin
Trevorrow and stars Chris Pratt and
Bryce Dallas Howard and I have been
waiting for this movie for 14 years if
you don't count Jurassic Park 3 I'm
waiting for a good Jurassic Park movie
for 18 years if we didn't like lost
world that's 22 years for goodness sakes
Jurassic Park is part of my life I
remember when I first saw Jurassic Park
I recorded it on two VHS tape from
television I must have watched that tape
a hundred times I have internal audio
memory of the various 90s commercials
that were included in the broadcast of
Jurassic Park on my VHS tape when I got
money of my own I bought my own VHS is
of it I bought the DVDs when they came
out I even bought the three blu-rays
that were released even though I'm not a
huge fan of Jurassic Park 3 and despite
having them I bought the freaking new
collection as well and I haven't even
opened it yet because I just want to
keep it in the plastic that's how much I
love Jurassic Park it has been part of
my life and my family and friends so
this review is from a true fan I love
Jurassic Park and I was pumped out of my
mind for Jurassic world which is about a
theme park called Jurassic world and
it's the encapsulation of John Hammonds
original vision that went sour in that
first film it's everything that he
wanted this place to be and it's now
fully operational and because of
diminishing returns they create a hybrid
dinosaur that's bigger with more teeth
to hopefully bring in more visitors and
when that thing gets out you know
dinosaurs eat people we've been here
before
but is it good yes it is I had a lot of
fun with Jurassic world now let me tell
you honestly this is a good movie it's
not a great movie in my opinion though
and I
gotta be honest with you I'm a humongous
fan such a huge fan but I'm also looking
at this movie as a movie you know there
are some flaws in the storytelling and
when you have a script that's been so
publicly fought over as to who gets the
rights to getting story credit and
screenplay credit and there's actual
lawsuits I'm not surprised that certain
elements of this screenplay just really
quite weren't up to par in my opinion
I'll discuss more of that later but
let's talk about the good first first
off Chris Pratt once again has proven
himself to be a fantastic actor for this
type of role he was great in guardians
of the galaxy and so many people have
been spreading rumors about Indiana
Jones 5 for a long time and him being
Indiana Jones I was like let's just see
how he is in Jurassic world he blew me
away in this movie he had a lot of
charisma he was good in the action
scenes his humor worked and he was just
the most likable character in the entire
film and this movie has proven to me
that if he were to ever take over
Indiana Jones I'd give him a salute I'd
be happy with that
good job proud you did a great job in
this movie and another thing that people
are really worried about was Bryce
Dallas Howard character because in the
trailers and the clips she seemed kind
of like just this person who kind of
stood around and said scientific stuff
she has a lot more to do in the movie no
spoilers for me but she definitely has a
lot more to do I like the direction her
character went it started off a bit
stale I must be completely honest about
the first 30 minutes of this movie I was
actually kind of sitting there going
when's it going to start which is not a
good thing because in my opinion
Jurassic Park and the lost world they're
always moving whether or not it's
dinosaur scene or just character sitting
around talking those two films really
moved in the first 30 minutes of this
film I was like let's get to it let's go
let's go and that might have something
to do with the fact that it takes a
while to introduce Chris Pratt into the
movie and once he finally came in there
I was like okay this is a likable
character I like the direction this is
going but I want to get really real here
okay I don't think any of you subscribe
to me for me to sugarcoat my reviews I
don't think any of you click Subscribe
going I like how this guy doesn't
actually say how he feels because I'm
going to tell you how I feel there's
some really poor characterization in
this movie there's a lot of characters
in this movie there's a lot of subplots
in this movie and some of those subplots
just don't need to be there in
particular the two kids there's a lot of
backstory with these kids with their
parents with their current adventure on
the island when they get kind of
separated which you've seen in the
trailer
and it just felt like the movie derailed
every time it cut back to them and I
kept going get back to Bryce Dallas
Howard and Chris Pratt that's where the
film is one of the things that people
were really worried about was the whole
Raptor training bit I can understand
that apprehension because the Raptors
are it's kind of like training jaws or
something there's such a scary cool
creature
you don't really wanted to be good guys
I'll put it this way I think the film
handled it very well and I think most
people will not be disappointed by it it
actually tugged at my heartstrings in a
couple moments and there are times with
those Raptors where it just worked for
me where the connection between Chris
Pratt and the Raptors may have been
actually the strongest emotionally
resonant connection between characters
in this film which is that's a little
sad I guess Jurassic Park in 1993
pioneered CGI so it's obvious now that
we've had better CGI and new CGI but is
it really better just because it's new
yes there is more detail but in the
original Jurassic Park film still I can
watch that movie and be like that looks
real and I talked about this in my jp3
review one of the reasons is Spielberg
utilized mostly just wide shots for CGI
anytime a creature was close up to the
screen or close up to an actor it was an
animatronic creature and that really
sold in this movie there is a lot of CGI
and for the most part it is good but
there is a little too much of an
over-reliance on it in my opinion and I
think it shows in some of the actors
performances because there's a lot of
staring at a tennis ball type looks in
this movie but seriously though I don't
want to get too negative here I don't
want to disappoint you guys I had fun
with this movie but today in this
Internet age I've noticed that a lot of
times it's either you love it or you
hate it if you're sort of in the middle
people don't really understand how to
feel I had a lot of fun with it in fact
everyone I saw it with tonight about
five six or seven of us we all were like
that was good
we had some flaws with it but we all
enjoyed the movie and that's how I feel
I enjoyed this movie I'm excited to see
it again and examine it again but there
are story flaws that couldn't really get
me into some of the characters the
direction at times was a little flat it
just wasn't enough energy in that
direction but really what can you expect
Steven Spielberg made Jurassic Park and
Schindler's List in the same year you
can't really get better than that
that's crazy so I didn't go into this
movie expecting it to be better I just
wanted to be good and you know what it
was I had a great time with this movie
the CGI for the most part works the
indominus rex as a big villain works
that thing is cool it is really cool and
there are some great uses of its genes
that it has in it I'll just put it at
that without spoiling anything there's
just some storytelling flaws here with a
film sometimes branches to other people
you're like does that person really need
that much screen time does that person
really need that much screen time let's
focus on our core here think about the
first Jurassic Park movie they had
almost every main character converge on
that dinner scene where they all talked
about their ideas of science you're
there to see dinosaurs but you're
watching these characters talk and for
some reason it's riveting that's because
good writing good directing and good
acting there weren't too many riveting
character moments in Jurassic world it
was mostly dinosaurs are on the loose we
got to hunt them down it wasn't really
that interesting it kind of took
Jurassic Park 3's straight up thriller
not much commentary on science or nature
it was just thriller let's have fun and
it is much better than Jurassic Park 3
much better don't get me wrong the last
30 minutes of this movie I loved loved
it felt like classic Jurassic Park had
such a great time with the last act of
this movie however with the way the
Internet is I can see two things being
brought up as major complaints that get
like a lot of thumbs up on places I
don't to be the first person to tell you
there's going to be people who are
talking about the fact that phones and
walkie-talkies they just don't work on
this incredibly advanced island filled
with scientific technology and there are
a lot of callbacks to Jurassic Park that
sometimes are very blatant that kind of
just come off as yeah Jurassic Park was
a good movie and we're gonna kind of
recreate that moment for you that's I
don't know guys seriously though I want
this to be super clear I am a humongous
Jurassic Park fan my heart was beating
on the universal logo showed up in this
movie I was ready I was almost
goose-bumpy already just from seeing the
universal logo the movie is a bit
disappointing from a story and character
perspective the dinosaurs work very well
there's a lot of great action there's
some subplots that don't really belong
in this movie but in the long run it is
a much better sequel than Jurassic Park
3 was and it confirms to me that Chris
Pratt is deaf
Leigha talent to watch out for he wasn't
just a one-hit wonder with Gardens the
galaxy that guy has got it he is very
good in this movie guys I'm gonna give
Jurassic world of B I can hear you now
disappointed about a grade but look I
had fun with the movie guys go check it
out for yourself make your own opinion
don't always listen to mine if you don't
want to see the movie don't see the
movie if you want to see it go see it
I'm just giving you my thoughts on it as
a dude in Ohio who really freaking loves
movies also I want to give a huge thank
you to Aaron Jay Morton he composed my
new opening and outro music you're about
to hear if you want to go check out his
Facebook page it is a linked below he's
an up-and-coming film composer he's
working on some films right now super
nice guy he wanted me to let you know
that his Facebook page is still in the
progression phase so if you don't see a
lot of likes and a lot of stuff on there
you wanted to make sure you guys knew
about that huge thank you Aaron for the
new music he basically took my old theme
and made it with actual instruments so
it's no longer stock GarageBand music so
I really appreciate that and guys in
previous weeks I have reviewed the lost
world and Jurassic Park 3 and I already
have an older review of Jurassic Park 3d
on my channel so if you guys want to
check out those reviews to know my
thoughts on the entire side of Jurassic
Park you can do that there on my channel
right now thank you so much guys
seriously for watching and just for
being awesome you guys Rock thank you if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuff my nice